It just,
and you ask a related question about
Elon Musk.
Yeah,
there've been wonderful things that he's
been talking about.
Colonizing Mars,
obviously putting a a,
a tesla and space,
which is playing David Bowie,
which I love.
He's a really wonderful person and an
inspiration to a lot of us.
And what are the misconceptions a lot of
people have is that federal space
programs like NASA and commercial space
programs like space x run by Elon Musk
are in some type of a,
uh,
competition.
And uh,
you know,
I am a fan of all things space and one
of the things that has been so fun for
me in the last few years is the
collaboration between those two
different realms of space travel.
So,
you know,
for example,
a NASA routinely buys space six rockets
to put our payloads and our satellites
up into space.
And that means that as a NASA scientist,
I've gotten to go to several launches
and landings of these Falcon rockets.
And that's amazing.
You know,
used to be that you would go to a launch
and a big rocket would go off and
everybody would cheer.
And then you get in your cars and you
drive home and it was all done.
The amazing thing now is seven minutes
later,
everybody just walks to the other side
of the building and watches the first
stage of that rocket land.
And that is something that is mind
blowing your eyes basically.
It does not compute.
You cannot believe what you were seeing
because this giant thing comes down from
space faster than you could imagine.
And this is something that's done.
You'll several story high building.
It's a big thing.
It comes careening down and just before
it gets to the ground,
it's stops,
settles down and then gently lands.
And one of the things that I love is
that you don't even hear the sonic boom
until after you see it land.
You watched this thing come careening
down than stop land gently and then you
hear boom,
boom,
because it broke the speed of sound
coming in.
And that is something that I am just
really amazed.
I live to be able to see.
I love space x and I love NASA is
collaboration.
I think what a lot of people don't
realize that NASA is one of space x as
major customers.
We actually buy the rockets and we've
even paid for some of the development of
the rockets as well.
So it was never a question of one or the
other.
It was a,
it was the idea is that we're
collaborating.
The more companies going into space,
hey,
the better for us.
The lower the cost of the rockets and
the more efficient an industry we have
and hopefully the more people that think
space,
travel and space exploration or good
things.
Then there are the questions about
whether Ilan is going to build a giant
rocket that can take hundreds of people
to Mars and then this is something that
as a scientist,
you know,
I am naturally a skeptical person.
That's how I was trained right now.
What I see is a really cool idea,
you know,
reminds me of a lot of my favorite
science fiction stories,
but it's basically just that an idea.
I think there's a long way to go before
we actually see any significant
colonization.
You know,
any significant number of people going
to Mars?
First we need to get one single to Mars,
you know,
or a small team of people.
And that is something that has proven
very,
very difficult.
It's not so much a question that we
can't build rockets to take us there
because even today,
you know,
we have rockets that might have the
capability of doing that.
The problem is how you would keep a crew
of people alive for the journey to Mars
and then also alive on the surface and
get them back.
That would be very expensive.
And because the astronauts would not be
protected from the radiation of space
right now,
we really don't know how to keep them
alive.
It's not impossible.
There's a lot of work that can be done,
but when I see people thinking that
space x is almost ready to send people
to Mars,
that's where I have a bit of a wait and
see attitude.
I would love to see people on Mars.
I would love to see space x take people
to Mars.
I think the Tesla up there heading out
toward the asteroid belt is so cool,
but there's a long way to go and it's
not easy.
I think we're not going to get there
from a single company or a single nation
even.
I think that for something as large as a
mission to Mars,
we need to collaborate on a global
scale.
You know,
work with the Europeans,
work with other emerging space markets,
maybe work with several different
companies,
not just one.
It's not a single entity.
It's a planet going out and exploring
something as big as colonizing Mars.
I mean,
that's an amazing civilization scale
activity.
I am somewhat skeptical that in my
lifetime I will see people walking on
Mars.
I hope we do.
I'm not holding my breath.
Okay.